i'm not allowed to talk about it at all
what do you mean
no no one's i'm going to tell you
something okay
no one's watching right because there's
big talk about a new goosebumps tv
series
viewers beware you're in for a scare
i feel like what better way to to kick
off spooky season
than with rl stein you know i know like
i come from this
you know mid 90s era goosebumps fandom
and i know you have a lot of fans in my
my age group so i'm just curious like
90s
we love the 90s so what is it like for
you when you go to like
you know cons or signings and you're
meeting fans and it's like you know
these
people in their mid-30s that just revert
to children as soon as they see you
no it took a while to get used to
because like when i do a book signing
there will be
year olds and 10 year olds right and 12
and then 25 and 30. at first i'd say
what are you doing here
what are you doing here we we loved you
when we were kids
and that's hard to get used to because i
realize
like i'm nostalgia to you
yeah how weird is that how would you
like to be nostalgia
that's very strange but i actually i
love it yeah
what's how lucky how lucky am i to be
able to
you know scare so many generations right
it's like people are like you scarred me
for life with that one book
how lucky is that it's it's pretty great
like
what would you say the number one thing
is that people say to you or ask you
when they see you
well they ask me where i get my ideas
everyone asks
everyone where do you get ideas
i always want to say where do you get
your ideas
because we all have ideas right yeah
yeah yeah do you have like a
sorry i'm out like asking anyone i feel
like but do you have like a
brainstorming process
that you do or do do you kind of just
like a title comes to you and then you
kind of take it from there
honestly that's what i do um this is my
whole secret
i don't try to think of ideas because
i've done every story a human can do
so i don't i absolutely never try to
think of ideas i only think of titles
and if i have a really good title then
it leads me to the story
i have a title in my head for the next
goosebumps i have to write
which is called the title is fifth grade
zombies
that's the next one what's the story
gonna be well there's a classroom
one classroom and the school is all
zombies
or maybe these fifth graders go out and
they're hypnotized
i i don't know what the story is yet but
the that title will lead me to a good
story
and that's my i think that's backwards
for most authors they get an idea they
write
later they think of a title but i have
to have the title first
i start with the title i was going to
say i feel like for a lot of people the
title is the hardest part
i that's that's my mainly my only talent
is thinking of titles og goosebumps the
series it's currently on netflix and
people are like kind of
rediscovering it or introducing their
kids to it or people are discovering it
on their own
have you revisited the series recently
the two movies helped
revitalize the series a lot with jack
black
playing me mm-hmm jack and i are like
twins right
yes definitely yes and um
so i you know but i haven't gone back i
i have a feeling the series is very 90s
very young it is but i just i don't know
i feel like it holds up maybe that's
like my own time capsule
looking back but i just i've been i've
been re-watching it
i'm not allowed to talk about it at all
what do you mean
luckily no no no one's i'm gonna tell
you something
okay no one's watching right because
there's big talk about a new goosebumps
tv series
okay i was gonna ask you this because
yeah
but i am not allowed to say anything not
that i know much
i mean okay now i want to ask you a
million questions though
it's like is it gonna be like episodes
that have already happened kind of like
a revamped version or like
the newer stuff well i hope it's the
newer stuff
okay i don't know i don't know no i
don't that's all i know
i mean i some people have optioned it
and they're ready to go and they're
going to
whenever people start making films and
tv again
there there's going to be a new series i
love
that they begged me not to talk about it
oh my gosh that's why i'm telling you
yes thank you thank you oh my gosh that
would be so exciting i would like
it's so crazy looking back too because
there's some of the most famous actors
like in the world working today that
just showed up on goosebumps in the 90s
well we used to you know it was totally
canadian the show
that we used every kid in canada that's
why ryan gosling is in say cheese and
die
11 year old ryan gosling don't you get
it
it predicts the future and it makes it
bad
if you can think back is there an
episode you feel like is like the
quintessential one or the one that
nailed it the most
definitely the haunted mask the first
one we filmed
about carly beth the girl who puts on
the green mask at
halloween time and it sticks to her face
and she can't get can't get it off and
it becomes part of her
um that's my all-time favorite my
monsters literally left off the page
as long as the books remain locked we're
safe but when they open
well you've just seen what happens
i feel like i waited my entire life for
a movie adaptation
and we finally got it um
were were you a fan it seems like you
are
of the goosebumps movies of the movies
yeah yes i love them
they were good they were good they're
good they didn't have to be
no they turned out to be good you never
know what you're going to get
i was so pleased i'm proud of both of
the goosebumps movies
and what a role to be a character in the
movie
i know jack black was amazing
i know we had a great time together
slappy it's
so nice to see you again did you miss me
would you say that slappy is like your
favorite villain of goosebumps
um i don't know how to answer that he's
my most
popular villain yeah my favorite
but he's by far the most popular villain
you know thousands of kids at halloween
time go out as slappy
dressed as slappy and last halloween i
did a
an appearance at a big theater in
toronto
40 kids came to my talk
dressed as slappy so he's very popular
my problem is i've written about 14
books about it
and there's not that much you can do
about a dummy that comes to life
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah many
stories left
and i have to because he's so popular i
have to keep writing slappy books
that's that's the curse of slappy you
gotta write him for the rest of your
life
i even killed him i wrote the ghost of
slappy
i killed him off but of course he had to
come back oh man
yeah that's like that's like misery
they're like you can't kill slappy he's
gotta come back
that's right right exactly misery that's
the word
that's kind of a big question but why do
you think that goosebumps has just stood
the test of time for so many people
well i think um everyone likes to a good
scary story
every age every people like to be scared
when they know they're safe
at the same time and i think that's the
whole secret to it
when kids pick up a goosebumps book now
they know it's going to be creepy
there's going to be all kinds of twists
and turns
but it's going to let them off okay like
a roller coaster
it's going to let them off and they're
going to be safe and sound
and it's never going to go too far and i
think that's
i think that's the appeal we all have
happy endings
once i wrote a fear of my other series
fear street
or the fear novel with an unhappy ending
where the murderer got off scot-free and
the innocent girl was taken away as a
murderer
and kids turned on me immediately they
hated that
dear r.l stein you [ __ ] you idiot
how could you write that so i never do
unhappy ending but i like to have like
a happy ending and then some little
twist at the end
some little twist yeah right that's
finally also being adapted you're
getting a lot of
adaptations they're filmed they're three
fair street movies
they're all filmed so we're just waiting
for them to come out now
well yes so am i
they were supposed to open this summer
the idea was to have binge
movie watching and that one would come
out in june
july and august i love that
that would you know and you'd go each
month and see a fear street movie but
then of course there are no movie
theaters
right right they're going to be on
netflix next year
so how closely do you work on your
adaptations
like the tv and the movies not not cl
no one asks me they have to i don't
believe that
no i'll tell you you want to know my
contribution to the goosebumps movie
yeah i had them remove two stephen king
jokes
why you're like sick of that comparison
bragging about
you know i don't brag i don't like to
say oh i'm a much better writer than he
is that kind of thing
i don't believe that yeah that was my
entire contribution to the movie
i i had no input at all nobody wants the
author around
ah i would i'd be like or else i need to
be on set every day oh no
people want to do their own version they
want to do their own thing
so i had i i had uh no input in the fear
street movies
so for the goosebumps movie like is
there anything that you would tweak
if you were if you were on set beyond
the stephen king just well i shouldn't
say i
if if i were doing the goosebumps movie
um
i mean and i already said i think
they're wonderful i i'm
so happy with both of them but i would
make them a little scarier
i would de-emphasize the funny stuff a
little bit
and i would make them i would make them
creepier do you have a favorite book
that you've written or is that like
picking a favorite child
that's really hard the new goosebumps
book
is called they call me the night howler
and it's a comic book one it's the best
goosebumps book i've written in about 10
years
i probably shouldn't say that should i
but they can't
be great you know yeah anyway it
i think it's the best one i've written
in the last 10 years
it's really a good one why why do you
think it's the best one
it just fits together it's funny it's
really creepy
the kids are great all the superheroes
in it are hilarious
i just like it you have a brand new
series inspired by
the garbage pail kids which is so
interesting it's launching on september
29th
what appealed to you about creating a
world around the garbage pail kids
well they're so gross and disgusting
they're horrible kids
so they're a lot of fun to write i don't
know i had to think about
this a lot garbage pail kids what am i
doing this may be a real career ender
for me
i don't know but uh i you know
i always was funny i never really
planned to be a scary guy
i always was funny i wrote joke books
for kids and
humor magazine so for me to be able to
return
to just be funny and write about these
crazy garbage pail characters
it's so it's i'm having a great time
with it i i love that you said that
because
whenever i watch interviews with you or
like you've done like funny or die
sketches i'm like rl stein is hilarious
i yeah that's all i ever really cared
about and then somehow i got
i got scary so how did that happen
were you oh it's embarrassing it wasn't
even my
idea my editor at scholastic my friend
she um at lunch one day she said
you could write a good scary novel for
teenagers go home and write a book
called blind date
she even gave me it was all her idea i
didn't think of it
i went home i wrote blind date it was a
number one bestseller
and i thought wait a minute forget the
funny stuff
and i've been scary ever since been
scary ever since
so how so the garbage pill kids it's you
it's more of a
a humorous book like how would you say
it differs from other things that fans
are familiar with
um it's sort of a cartoon it's like a
crazy cartoon
that's the way i think of it when i'm
writing it you have these 10
weird weird kids cranky frankie
rob slobb luke puke
all these kids 10 kids living in a house
by themselves
no parents they don't know how they got
there they don't know
why they're so weird and across the
street
lives a family called the perfect family
and their kids are perfect and they're
all perfect and so they have
natural born enemies right across the
street
it's just crazy so how many books are
going to be in this series
well i'm signing up for three so far and
we'll see
started goosebumps i said let's do two
or three
oh my gosh yeah and now it's the 28th
year year of goosebumps so you shouldn't
listen to me
you never know what i'm saying what is a
typical day in the life
of rl stein do you write every day or do
you kind of do adverse
pretty much i get up take it easy
we're out i i left the city we live in
new york but i'm
we're in sag harbor new york okay summer
house and we have a big pool
and um it's quite nice but i i usually i
write from like i
i try to write 2 000 words a day which
is like 10 pages
yeah and then i'm pretty much brain dead
go sit by the pool
i need a page out of your book it's
spooky season i know your birthday's in
october like what does rl stein's
spooky season look like what's your
ideal halloween what
halloween i'm always working i'm out
talking about myself
i'm out you know i'm almost never home
but if we are home in the city
we always uh you know we give out candy
and books
every year i feel like you're uh you're
a king-sized candy bar guy
yeah we get we don't give out the
fun-sized ones that's right
is that fun-sized no we won't do that